o OK agora começou então a gente que eu
vou falar como já apresentava como que a
gente pode sair dessas caixinhas de
humanas e exatas que eu sempre achei que
dizer sempre não' que hoje eu acho meio
bestas e fazer coisas legais sem isso eu
sei que apresentaram mas eu quero te
apresentar para vocês como me apresenta
para o mundo assim que é Basicamente já
me abriu o Twitter eu sou um cara de um
ano essa espere cólicas eu já explico
que significa mas basicamente quando eu
entrei no jornalismo o meu sonho a
trabalhar na revista Piauí não sei se
cês conhecem revista Piauí é uma revista
gigantesca de 20 ela cada reportagem tem
20 páginas são super literárias que
acontece o repórter sai com um bloquinho
na mão fala com um monte de gente
descreve a cena que escreve a roupa do
entrevistado e sim um jornalismo muito
Raiz e muito de humanas e meu sonho era
fazer isso só que alguma coisa deu
errado no meio do caminho e hoje eu
trabalho com uma de programação e com
dados o tempo todo quando eu percebi eu
tava numa escola de computação em Nova
York estudando coisas tipo isso aqui
esse monte de código e le
o antes e que é uma expressão regular
não vale a pena explicar uma expressão
regular agora mas é uma coisa muito nerd
que você pega texto e transforma em dado
estruturado e assim depois eu comecei a
gostar dessas coisas Não só expressão
regular mas nem matemática discreta
nesse de estatística estudei estrutura
de dados incêndio eu comecei a gostar
muito disso eu queria entender e comecei
a pensar porque eu passei 20 anos sem
perceber que exatas a tão legal quanto
humanos e tenho parentes aqui para quem
a Giovana só tem humanas exatas Você é
de biológicas e já exatas assim sinto
muito e a minha fala hoje tem assim...
Principais o primeiro tentar entender
por que que a gente se isola em Ilhas
porque a gente acha eu sou de humanas
então não sei fazer nenhuma conta porque
eu sou de exatas não sei ler cocô sabe
como que a gente rompe essa lógica que
que a gente ganha com isso e vamos
começar do ponto do primeiro. Lógico um
pouco da minha história eu acho que
porque não é PG também que vestibular
aqui talvez é só um pouco com vocês
assim até terceira série eu tinha duas
diferença eu gostava muito
a história faz todo sentido por ser de
humanas e matemática aqui não faz muito
sentido e eu gostava das duas coisas e
fui muito bem até aparecer em frações e
números negativos e eu não entendia nada
e tentaram explicar não você pega e faz
um X e o de cima Multiplica pelo debaixo
e o sinal diferente virar positivo não
sei lá nem sei até hoje e eu comecei a
me sentir muito burro eu acho que eu não
é que eu não gostava de matemática eu
não gostava de ser burro eu me senti
assim cara como é que eu não entendo
isso isso já é um trauma eu acho que tem
muita gente que depositar uma de
matemática ou trauma de exatas ou trauma
de física só que tá uma maior fim do
mundo assim viver basicamente era
superado da Alma eu fiquei um outro
calma por exemplo tinha medo de telefone
eu não consegui pegar o telefone assim
até ligar e pedir pizza eu tinha ficar
muito nervoso Só que os pé isso porque
porque eu tive incentivo se eu ligasse
pedisse pinça eu chegar uma pinta na
minha casa isso é um baita no incentivo
só que qual que é o incentivo para a
gente estudar tipo qualquer me sentindo
aprender matemática
e esse é o incentivo Esse é o cartaz
vestibular que eu fiz um repetindo 2011
ela pedir você fazer uns cartazes no
meio diferentes eu acho e enfim o
vestibular ele define em grande medida
como é que a gente se relaciona com o
conhecimento talvez não tanto na
terceira série mas 7ª série 8ª série 1º
ano 2º ano no cursinho a gente estuda
para passar no vestibular eu escolhi o
meu curso eu vejo hoje porque ele tinha
questões específicas de humanas que eu
sabia resolver e eu respondi nesse
vestibular 74 que eu tenho de humanas e
só 22 questões de qualquer outra coisa
fora redação tem uma coisa meio de um
ano e eu percebi que se eu estudar só
humana seu passado eu tinha que tirar
uns setenta por cento da prova para
passar bem tranquilo e que eu fiz foi e
falei de todas as altas eu só estudava
específica fazer a prova específica e eu
Passei no vestibular e deu certo e isso
é um problema porque já na porta de
entrada assim da Universidade que a
porta de entrada na vida adulta que a
pouco a gente começa a produzir
conhecimento ele é um profissional a
gente a gente que tem orgulho de ficar
numa caixinha ficasse de um ano seja
assim ter muito colegas muitos colegas
Olá eu sou de humanas não sei preserva
de três assim mesmo não me faz falta eu
tinha colega de fazer engenharia os
caras não iam nada além de livro tá é
que ele pediu não porque eu gosto de
coisa assim mais uma dois assim vai Isso
é um problema acho que é um problema
meio auto-evidente não tem que explicar
por que que são problema tem que pensar
como que a gente vamos essa lógica e
assim eu podia propor uma revolução aqui
tipo acabar com o vestibular acabar com
a divisão de Eu acho que isso é muito
legal assim não tem mais departamento de
letras não tem departamento de
Matemática é tudo misturado só que isso
não vai acontecer né tá assim 200 anos
ou mais e a gente tem que achar uma
solução mais simples Eu acho que a
solução mais simples é mostrar para as
pessoas que ia separação do conhecimento
na prática talvez não na academia não do
vestibular ela nem sequer meramente
formal assim na prática ela não acontece
muito e uma tarefa
a passar na minha pós-graduação que eu
acho que foi que me ajudou a ver se é
separação ser tão artificial foi com o
professor que a poeta e Engenheiro ele
já era meio doidão sem ele mandou atrás
que assim você tem dois temas eu quero
que vocês trabalham contra uma relação
entre eles faça um ensaio para mim
contigo primeiro tem nesse caso aqui
Jorge Luis Borges para quem não conhece
um escritor argentino escritor e
bibliotecário está está contista poeta
ensina um cara muito de humanas ele
escreveu um texto chamado a biblioteca
de Babel que essa biblioteca de Babel
era Realismo Fantástico então uma
biblioteca gigantesca que têm todos os
livros de todo o conhecimento que a
humanidade já produziu e poderia
produzir no futuro e o grande drama é
que tem pessoas que estão circulando com
essa biblioteca assim de cargos na
cabeça e tocha na mão procurando um
livro que tem a verdade da humanidade
passado o presente o futuro livro
específico que tem de Cultura se eu
quiser saber que elas nunca acharam esse
livro biblioteca era muito grande não
tive uma ideia de procurar então ficam
vagando por toda eternidade não achava
uma resposta
e em segundo tá isso aqui eu acho que
alguém de exatas aqui de computação sabe
que são um banco de dados mas não vou
explicar exatamente que tinha uma árvore
surge a árvore mas aqui assim desde
computação existe as pessoas estão muito
preocupadas em Como organizar informação
para computador quando vai pesquisar um
arquivo uma palavra uma entrada ele acha
as coisas emagreci sente se eu for livro
por livro entrada por entrada eu vou
demorar toda a eternidade para achar um
dado seu desenhar um banco de dados de
uma forma pouco mais longe que o
computador consegue achar informação de
forma mais eficiência e é muito louco
como esse caro Jorge Luis Borges em 44
acho que escreveu o texto 16 anos depois
pessoas fico daí BMG da Computação sabe
só defesa depois a gente preocupada com
a mesma coisa mesma coisa como que eu
vou achar essa maldito livro esse
maldito conhecimento e assim eles estão
muito distantes mas o tempo que eles
estão trabalhando ao mesmo um gerando
poesia e outro gerando Engenharia e
quando você parar para pensar nesse caso
não né sessão assim eu penso as pessoas
que eu gosto filósofos caras que
e esse trabalho muito nessas duas partes
assim dele de qualquer forma se ele foi
um setor americano que tinha uma coisa
de pegar a linha de pensamento e até o
final falar de relacionamento sociedade
contemporânea capitalismo um monte de
coisa muito de humanas mas livro que eu
mais gosto dele sistema Everything menor
que é um livro sobre filosofia da
Matemática ao infinito então ele
trabalhando com a linguagem dele o jeito
uma lista dele as consequências de
várias equações que provaram que
infinito existe existe mais um Infinito
infinito exponencial influência sobre
exponencial de um livro muito bom as
Imóveis é o cara que escreveu eu roubou
uma série de contos que as leis da
robótica E como que os robôs não se
comportaram no futuro e quais são as
obras obras desde eles têm que obedecer
só que esse cara também a bioquímico ele
dava aula Universidade de Boston que Mas
elas são meio conflituosos aqui ele não
gostava de pesquisar não é só de dar
aula e escrever só que assim a escrever
o que tu de ficção que ele escrevi Aqui
cansei de ficar dura que chama o que tem
de mais verossímil que parece real ao
contrário de um
a causa máquina do tempo porque ele
tinha essa formação científica exatoide
biológico e permitia que ele escrevesse
daquele jeito convencido de que escrever
outro cara Bertrand Russell vocês devem
conhecer ele como Nobel de Literatura de
vista político Pensador só que ele
escreveu 1900 princípios no livro
chamado princípios lógicos matemáticos
que é basicamente o princípio da lógica
formal que guia uma computação e
matemática até hoje e foi uma ativista
político foi militante guerra é um cara
que tá ali dentro as duas coisas a gente
vai voltando no tempo Isaac Newton
Newton perdão ele é físico Óbvio Mas ele
também escreveu sobre teologia escrever
sobre a Bíblia ele também foi de um
partido político Monarquia
Constitucional britânico então o cara
que era política e era natas e você
volta que Aristóteles ação exemplo o
cara os gregos pensavam matemática
pensavam triângulos geometria é só uma
vida na cidade na Pólis e política então
a separação ela é de papel quando a
gente entende que se muro
E aí de papel e não é um muro na
realidade a nossa vida melhor muito e
agora eu vou tentar mostrar o que que a
gente ganha com isso quando a gente
derruba esse mundo sabe e agora eu vou
voltar um pouco a ser jornalista para
responder com o exemplo dos meu trabalho
de meus colegas como que a gente está
tentando romper isso uma redação assim
essa uma reportagem que Meus
concorrentes e amigos a folha publicaram
eles pegaram o Enem 2018 sai um dos
microdados neném e você tem por exemplo
cada prova você tem a sequência de
respostas e se eu tenho perfil não tem o
nome da pessoa tem um perfil essa pessoa
que fez essa prova que a resposta é ABC
e ABC e ela é uma pessoa de chissano
sair da cidade e tal você tem tipo
milhões de provas e com a chave
respostas delas eles analisaram da
seguinte maneira quando você acerta uma
questão você eu todo mundo consegue
acertar de uma maneira só só tem uma
resposta correta mas quando você erra
você pode errar de quatro maneira Você
pode marcar as quatro alternativas que
sobram e as pessoas têm e rádio maneira
diferente
e é muito improvável que você vai errar
uma questão igual tem uma chance de um
quarto só que é uma chance pequena e o
que os caras perceberam é que tinha
muita gente errando igual eles erravam
da mesma maneira que eles acertaram as
questões e quando errado né Rafa
marcando berrava marcando certifique-se
indica ele soltinho gabarito o último
alguém sofreu número deles a resposta
essa reportagem da investigação do
Ministério Público que eu não sei
infecta a meditar andando ainda mas qual
que é a chave do cara que pensou esse
método quantitativo um biólogo Daniel
Mariano biólogo infografia e jornalista
deve trabalhar na relação faz uns 10
anos só que ele pesquisava genética seu
porventura animada que eu não conheço
quase nada mas a tela que eles fazem
aquele ficou tanto tempo vendo base
nitrogenada adenina adenina-guanina a
CTG CTG ele pegou e viu elencar a mesma
coisa então ele pegou esse conhecimento
quantitativo dele dentro de uma cultura
de redação uma coisa investigativa ele
colaborou com outros hipótese também
navegavam nessas duas áreas para todas
essas pessoas não tá em contato com as
escolas
a informação mesmo sobre uma coisa para
distrair por exemplo esses caras que
tinham esse padrão de trem de respostas
saímos um grande centro para fazer prova
no interior Então tinha alimentos muito
forte de fraude que não foi comprovada
pela reportagem mas que abriu uma
investigação crítica e essa outra
reportagem na reportagem que agora eu
vou mesa de um pouco a minha que fez
então que eu acho que tá furado e foi
uma união da minha equipe de infografia
digital programadores envolvedores um
like mais tradicional de viagem e a
gente volta uma repórter tá fazer um
roteiro em museu do Prado na Espanha que
é o museu mais antigo maior acervo de
arte da Espanha tem seus 200 anos fato
pouco e ela apontou as coisas mais
interessantes que tinham a sala você tem
as meninas Velázquez e tem muitas
pinturas de Goya 70 coisas do Bosco
Jardim das Delícias terrenas eu sabia
tudo isso só que ele tem uma ideia meio
doida de avaliar se os dados de uma
grande diferente das nossas pinturas né
mas pinturas são Dados que você pega uma
imagem Ok a pincel é a arte de uma
representação muito subjetivo ali mas
quando você bota isso no computador
o site 0101 Excel é forno que a gente
fez ele chegou na Inteligência
Artificial que comprar o cada uma dessas
imagens com outras 3.017 nessa parece
com essa essa parece com essa essa
parece com essa essa parece com essa e
falou computador volta essa 6 mil
imagens um plano 2D para gente brincar a
gente começou a ver as imagens parecidas
pernas uma das outras a gente sobre
coisas que eu não sabia porque esse cara
aqui vou exigir de uma ele me desses ele
é um pintor espanhol ele deve ter eu
acho que é o segundo cara com mais obras
expostas no prazo expostas no prazo tem
500 600 obras sei lá ele pintava o poder
Gomes espanhol que a natureza morta com
coisas típicas da culinária espanhola
Davi espanhola cotidiana outro cara era
um que eu não vou lembrar o nome
infelizmente mas ele pintava paisagens a
Espanha quem tava grama pintava céu quem
tava montanha e ficou outra nuvem ali
então a gente descobriu no mar e que
geralmente é muito têm um certo
preconceito com coisa quantitativa e tal
que é jornalismo cultural tem muita
coisa a inspiração do repórter a gente
usou uma letra diferente
é para expor ao museu mais tradicional
Europa 11 museus nacionais da Europa e
descobrir coisas que a gente não
consegui descobrir um jeito que a gente
usou computação e tecnologia passar
ângulos novos e uma matéria de
jornalismo muito cultural em suma o que
eu queria dizer que quando você quebra
esse muro que eu tentei mostrar atrás
que é um muro muito de papel a gente
começa a ver coisas quente nenhum
viagens a gente começa a pensar de forma
que a gente não vi a gente sabe que o
ponto de vista humano Isso é muito bom a
gente conversar aprender muito mais e
pensar de uma forma diferente só que
isso também pode ajudar Pagar boleto e
eu queria terminar a palestra com uma
frase um cara que eu pude conversar
quando eu fazer essa bosta que eu levo e
puxa não é nem o de todo mundo que tá
fazendo favor isso assim é muito fácil
encontrar um repórter o bom fogo aqui
estão bom pagar amadora só que é muito
difícil encontrar uma pessoa que consiga
ter tudo isso e fazer uma coisa muito
doida é muito diferente eu acho que
também deve ser muito fácil encontrar um
ótimo estatístico um ótimo Engenheiro um
ótimo programa adoro mas é um pouco mais
difícil encontrar alguém que consiga
unir tudo isso no trabalho que tem
propósito e que nova e quebra barreiras
e muito obrigado a
E aí
[Aplausos]